Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Salut les lardons. Aujourd'hui n'est pas une journée ordinaire puisque j'ai eu le plaisir de me rendre à la Tour des Finances pour interviewer nulle autre que Zakia Khattabi,
ministre fédérale du Climat, de l'Environnement, du Développement durable et du Green Deal.
Ce qui est de plus en plus ordinaire, malheureusement, c'est le retard énorme que j'ai accumulé puisque ça fait à nouveau deux mois que je n'ai pas sorti d'épisode.
On en reparle en fin d'émission. Ensemble, avec Zakia Khattabi, on a parlé de féminisme, de politique et vous vous en doutez bien, d'écologie.
Une interview qui pourra en surprendre plus d'un, car ses positions ne sont pas forcément celles qu'on attend sur ces sujets.
On retrouve sans plus attendre Zakia Khattabi. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Zakia Khattabi. Zakia Khattabi, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Tu es ministre fédérale belge du Climat, de l'Environnement, du Développement durable et du Green Deal et tu as été coprésidente d'Ecolo entre 2015 et 2019.
Est-ce que j'ai oublié quelque chose ?
J'ai été la candidate malheureuse à un poste à la Cour constitutionnelle.
OK, ok, c'est intéressant parce que j'avais même pas prévu d'en parler parce que j'ai l'impression qu'on a tout dit là-dessus.
C'est-à-dire que ce qui reste à dire, c'est dommage, 'fin voilà, etc.
Bien sûr.
Ça reste douloureux. Il y a un échec personnel. 'fin, j'en rêvais, mais cette aventure m'a fait grandir.
Et donc beaucoup s'attendaient à ce que je sois dans la revanche et dans la volonté de... et alors, c'est tout à fait l'inverse.
Parce que ça a été tellement dur et tellement violent et tellement, et c'était pas général, c'était moi parce que moi, c'était vraiment Zakia Khattabi qui était...
Ça m'a beaucoup fait réfléchir sur les dynamiques en jeu entre politiques et je me suis dit que je ne voulais pas, moi, être à l'origine
des sentiments que moi, j'ai eus, qui étaient très durs, que je voulais pas être à l'origine de ces sentiments chez un autre collègue.
Et donc ça m'a profondément changé. Et donc je fais très attention aujourd'hui à mes propos. Donc, je continue à être critique, etc.
Mais vraiment, je suis attentive à ne pas toucher l'homme ou la femme en tant que tel, parce qu'à l'occasion de cette affaire, j'étais beaucoup au contact.
'fin, après le premier échec, j'ai fait ma campagne quoi, j'étais à la rencontre pour essayer de comprendre ce qu'on me reprochait, etc.
Et je me suis rendu compte que parfois, pour une formule sympathique en interview, j'avais touché quelqu'un et c'était pas du tout l'objectif.
Et donc parfois, à mon avis, voilà, on ne mesure pas toujours l'impact, parce qu'on est emballé dans un jeu médiatique, etc.
Et donc ça, c'est vraiment un apprentissage que j'ai fait qui m'a... bon d'abord, ça a été dur, dur à encaisser, mais vraiment qui m'a renforcée. Voilà, donc.
Donc pas de rancœur, pas d'esprit revanchard à ce niveau-là, mais quand même-
Mais j'oublie pas.
Voilà. Voilà.
Voilà, oui, bien sûr.
Un souvenir qui reste bien, bien présent, je vois.
Oui, oui.
J'aurais aussi pu dire dans ma liste que tu te décris toi-même comme quelqu'un de solitaire, voire même parfois asocial.
Donc ça, j'approuve très fort puisque je me reconnais tout à fait là-dedans. Mais du coup, les interviews comme celle-ci, tu les acceptes à contrecœur ?
L'échange comme ça, le dialogue vraiment conversationnel, comme ce qu'on va faire maintenant. Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que tu fais facilement ?
Puisque ce n'est pas ton premier podcast.
Si, c'est l'exercice que j'affectionne le plus parce que précisément, on prend le temps et on développe et c'est dans une interaction, en duel, j'ai envie de dire.
Et on est vraiment dans la relation. Moi, ce que je n'aime pas, c'est... 'fin voilà, c'est vrai que je suis pas une fêtarde, 'fin voilà, etc.
Moi, je suis plus sur la qualité de la relation que la quantité. Et oui, c'est vrai que je suis une grande solitaire, mais en fait, j'ai une sœur jumelle.
Et à mon avis, mais bon, ça, je ferai, dans mon grand âge, j'irai sans doute un jour m'allonger pour essayer de comprendre.
Je pense que, donc quand on était enfant, donc ma sœur jumelle s'appelle Zineb et j'ai toujours cru que je m'appelais Zineb Zakia, puisque quand on appelait l'une, on appelait l'autre.
Donc, j'ai toujours entendu les deux prénoms ensemble et donc voilà. Alors peut-être que cette volonté d'être plus solitaire ou unique dans le sens unité est peut-être de là.
Elle a un tempérament beaucoup plus,
beaucoup plus sociable que moi. Mais c'est vrai que quand je dis ça et puis que les gens apprennent à me connaître, ils sont très surpris parce qu'ils trouvent que ça ne correspond pas,
à ce que je dis de moi, mais je pense que je suis dans la qualité de la relation.
Donc quand je suis en relation, je suis très attentive à la relation. Donc, je suis ravie d'avoir l'occasion d'échanger avec toi et en profondeur en plus.
Une très bonne réponse. Mais ça surprend quand même pour une politicienne, quelqu'un qui est dans le contact des gens, qui doit entendre les plaintes.
Il faut être charismatique, il faut plaire pour être élu. On a l'impression que c'est incompatible.
Le tempérament solitaire et le tempérament politique, politicienne, charismatique, électoral, etc.
Bah, il faut croire que non, puisque-
Oui, c'est vrai
Ma carrière va bien. Mais par contre, là où je te rejoins, c'est que je ne suis pas une grande fan, 'fin en tout cas, je ne suis pas bonne dans la légèreté, pour le dire un peu rapidement.
Et je ne suis pas une bonne politicienne, ça, c'est vrai.
D'accord.
Mais par contre, pour moi, la politique, c'est pas un jeu, en fait. Je veux dire, je m'amuse pas à un jour affirmer quelque chose et puis changer d'avis avec le sens du vent, etc.
C'est cet auteur qui écrivait que la politique était une question de vie ou de mort. C'est presque ça pour moi.
Et donc c'est très sérieux. Donc du coup, dans la relation avec les gens et dans les échanges que j'ai sur des engagements que je peux prendre, etc., c'est très important et les gens perçoivent ça.
Alors, ils savent que quand je suis là, je suis là à cent pour cent et quand je suis pas là, je suis pas là.
Mais donc non, c'est pas incompatible, c'est une autre manière de le faire. Voilà, moi, je suis très mauvaise, par exemple, en campagne sur les marchés, parce que là où certains,
voient, distribuent deux cents tracts, moi, j'en aurais distribué que vingt parce que je prends le temps, je prends le temps avec les gens.
Mais du coup, le contact est plus intéressant. C'est vrai que les gens sur un marché, ils rencontrent tout le politique qui est en campagne.
Et donc, je reste marquée par mes rencontres, mais je pense que les gens sont marqués aussi
par la rencontre avec moi, qu'ils soient marqués positivement ou négativement, hein, ici, je porte pas de jugement, mais je trouve important, on doit ça aux gens et je pense que c'est lié au
Voilà, moi, je viens d'un milieu social plutôt populaire, où le politique, au-delà des grands discours, ne s'est jamais préoccupé.
Moi, il y a jamais un politique qui a parlé à mon papa ou ma maman de manière... Quand ils l'ont fait, c'était de manière électoraliste, etc.
Et donc je reste marquée par ça et je ne souhaite pas, moi, reproduire ce profil et ce modèle-là de politique. Donc, je trace ma route et ça va.
Donc cette idée de servir la cause avant de servir son ego personnel et de se voir grandir quand on sert des vingtaines de mains sur un... ou des centaines de mains sur un marché en période électorale.
Est-ce que tu te reconnais dans la personnalité de Bernie Sanders aux États-Unis qui est aussi très fort comme ça un peu ?
Il y a cette fameuse photo où on le voit avec ses mitaines, très très à l'écart du monde et qui est aussi quelqu'un de très passionné par rapport aux idées.
Est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui t'évoque des...
Enfin, je me suis jamais posé la question comme ça. Mais c'est vrai. Enfin, en tout cas, le fait de ne... Enfin, ici, par exemple, mon équipe de la COP, mais en partie, tout le monde dit : C'est vrai que je ne cherche pas.
Je suis pas dans la séduction, on cherche pas à plaire. Voilà, ça, c'est clair. Et-
Lui, il dit : Je ne vous appellerai pas le jour de votre anniversaire. Parce qu'on téléphone juste pour le principe.
C'est ça, oui, oui. Tout à fait. Alors ça, moi, je dis pas parce que je le fais, mais je le fais avec les gens avec qui je suis en relation.
Enfin, voilà, quelqu'un que je ne connais pas, non. Mais aussi, non, je trouve que c'est... Il y a aussi des signaux qu'on donne à certains, qu'on donne pas à d'autres.
Ici, par exemple, au gouvernement, on se souhaite tous un bon anniversaire, on s'envoie des messages, etc. Mais moi, je le fais aussi avec mes collaborateurs et ils le font aussi.
Donc je pense qu'il y a aussi des-
Tu n'es pas au level Sanders non plus, en termes de-
Non, à ce niveau-là. Mais j'enverrai pas un bon anniversaire à un journaliste que je connais pas. Enfin voilà, il faut que... Moi, j'essaie toujours de mettre du sens dans quelque chose.
Donc voilà, oui, oui.
Alors, on va parler de beaucoup de choses ensemble. On va parler de féminisme, entre autres, tout à l'heure. Avant ça, si on parle un petit peu de ta jurisprudence en tant que ministre de l'Environnement,
l'OCDE a remis un rapport il y a quelques semaines où il était clairement exprimé que la Belgique n'était pas en très bonne position pour atteindre les objectifs de développement durable en deux mille trente.
Donc un mauvais bulletin, pour ainsi dire, donc pour la Belgique, en termes de biodiversité, de qualité de l'air, du mix énergétique, voilà, de ce genre de choses.
À ce stade de l'explication, généralement, on s'arrête pour dire que c'est plutôt de la faute de la région flamande qui a des ambitions bien moindres en ce qui concerne sa politique énergétique et le climat.
Est-ce que tu es d'accord avec ce constat ? Et si c'est le cas, comment est-ce qu'on explique cette particularité flamande ?
Alors, plusieurs choses. Donc d'abord, il y avait aucune surprise dans ce rapport, hein. Je veux dire, les rapports, ils se suivent et se ressemblent.
La Commission a fait une évaluation assassine de notre PNEC, le Plan national énergie climat, avec les mêmes remarques et le Bureau européen de l'environnement aussi.
Donc, pas de surprise. Alors, c'est vrai que la Flandre a une responsabilité parce qu'elle tire la moyenne vers le bas.
Mais elle n'est pas que... il n'y a pas qu'elle qui est responsable de cette... D'abord, dans le passé, je pense, tant en région wallonne qu'en région bruxello-fédérale, on n'a jamais été aussi ambitieux qu'aujourd'hui, hein.
Donc, à mon avis, de manière globale, il y avait un manque d'ambition général, hein, avec la Flandre qui avait encore un peu moins d'ambition.
Mais par ailleurs, je pense que, et c'est un des éléments que l'OCDE pointe, le fait de ne pas vouloir avoir ou adopter une vision intégrée malgré que les compétences soient éclatées, nous fait perdre aussi des points, hein.
On sait par exemple que la politique énergétique, elle est aux mains des régions. Mais par exemple, pour ce qui concerne les performances énergétiques des bâtiments,
quand bien même c'est une compétence dans les mains d'Alain Maron ou de ma collègue Zoë Aldem, etc., à mon avis, on gagnerait en efficacité s'il y avait aussi un dialogue entre eux, de telle sorte que, voilà, on,
on partage les expériences et des expertises des régions, voilà, des projets qui ont fonctionné, etc.
Donc, on a une marge d'amélioration rien que dans le fait de collaborer dans la construction de nos politiques plutôt que de travailler en silo.
Un manque de cohérence, un manque d'interrelation.
Oui, entre les régions. Mais aussi, alors ici, c'est pour ce qui concerne mon gouvernement propre, et c'est vrai aussi pour l'ensemble des gouvernements, c'est qu'on n'a pas non plus de vision intégrée,
par exemple, à l'échelle fédérale, de la politique climatique.
Ça n'a jamais été fait. Et donc on avait des ministres du Climat qui géraient le climat, mais sans mettre leur nez dans les affaires des collègues, en agriculture, en finances, etc.,
de telle sorte que l'ensemble des leviers politiques soient mobilisés en vue d'améliorer nos performances.
Et donc c'est ce qu'on fait ici. Hein, ici, moi, j'ai déposé... donc je suis ministre du Climat-
Mh.
Mais je n'ai pas de levier en tant que tel politique pour atteindre ces objectifs. Je ne vais pas, moi, à partir de mon département, atteindre les moins cinquante-cinq pour cent que le fédéral s'est attribué à lui-même.
C'est parce que je vais en dialogue avec mon collègue de l'Agriculture, avec mon collègue de la Régie des bâtiments, avec mon collègue de la Mobilité, etc., etc.
Et où j'assigne à chacun,
en discussion avec eux, avec leur administration, des objectifs clairs. Voilà. Donc, je pense qu'il y a, au-delà, effectivement, des différences entre les entités fédérées, il y a aussi, au sein d'un même gouvernement,
une nécessité d'une politique
intégrée et du fait de sortir des politiques en silo et de penser que le ministre du Climat, c'est que moi.
Moi, je dis à mes collègues : Il y a dans ce gouvernement... Vous êtes tous ministres du Climat avec moi.
Oui. Donc, tu joues un rôle, quelque part, de diplomate, voilà, chargée de mettre en accord les différents niveaux de pouvoir, les différentes entités fédérées.
Donc ça, c'est assez clair. On va y revenir dans un instant. Mais avant ça, j'aimerais revenir à un élément de ma question qui est : Mais pourquoi ?
Pourquoi est-ce que, en plus de ce manque de cohérence des différentes régions, on a tendance systématiquement à pointer du doigt la région flamande ?
Est-ce que c'est justifié ? Et comment expliquer historiquement le fait que la Flandre réagit comme ça ?
Donc plusieurs éléments. Ici, pour ces dernières années, il y a un agenda politique qui vient phagocyter tout le reste.
Et donc, il y a un agenda politique qui refuse de montrer que les régions peuvent encore collaborer avec le fédéral.
Et donc, c'est comme ça que pendant très très longtemps, la position de la Belgique dans les instances internationales était de s'abstenir sur des ambitions élevées, etc.
Donc là, c'est un autre agenda, qui est l'agenda nationaliste, qui s'impose et qui fait du mal à l'agenda climatique. Ça, c'est un.
Deux, il y a une réalité économique et industrielle en Flandre qui est différente des autres régions, hein. Il y a le port d'Anvers, il y a l'industrie chimique.
On sait que le poids des émissions de ces secteurs-là. Et donc il faut avoir une attention particulière pour avancer avec ces secteurs-là dans la transition.
Le problème, c'est que le politique, plutôt à la manœuvre en Flandre, plutôt que d'accompagner la transformation, se fait le syndicat des voix les plus conservatrices.
Moi, je suis en contact permanent avec les acteurs institutionnels flamands. Je suis en dialogue avec Essentia, le secteur de la chimie, avec le port d'Anvers.
Et je me rends compte qu'ils sont plus ambitieux que leur ministre. Et donc, il y a comme ça, le débat est brouillé et phagocyté par l'agenda nationaliste.
Et puis, il y a, je l'ai dit, des réalités économiques dont il faut tenir compte. Mais ça n'empêche pas de se donner un objectif ambitieux et de se mettre d'accord sur le chemin pour arriver à cet objectif ambitieux.
Donc, mettre en accord les différentes entités fédérées pour avoir une politique cohérente et arriver à, voilà, les tenir par la main et jusqu'à arriver à l'objectif.
Mais comment du coup ? Quel va être ton plan pendant ce mandat pour y arriver, sachant que ça a été toujours une difficulté jusque-là ?
Alors donc, j'ai ma feuille de route au fédéral. Et puis, il y a une instance dans laquelle on discute. C'est le Conseil national, le Conseil national climat.
Ce sont les CIM, les Conférences interministérielles de l'environnement. Donc moi, j'ai eu la présidence de l'instance de concertation sur nos politiques climatiques en décembre pour un mois, parce qu'on avait pris.
Aujourd'hui, c'est dans les mains de mon collègue wallon Philippe Henry. C'est lui qui préside cette commission. Et donc, il réunit régulièrement et les cabinets et les administrations, pour organiser la discussion.
On sait que, euh, en,
au mois de juin, l'Europe va revenir vers nous, parce qu'en décembre, nous avons élevé l'objectif européen à moins cinquante-cinq pour cent d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre sur le continent.
La Commission est en train de mettre à jour du coup tous ces objectifs et toutes ces politiques et elle va revenir vers les États membres pour assigner à chaque État son propre objectif.
Voilà. Quand la Belgique se verra assigner un objectif, c'est là que Philippe, puisqu'il est à la manœuvre comme président, va devoir organiser une négociation pour la répartition de cet effort.
Et ce n'est pas simple, c'est un vrai exercice, c'est un vrai exercice politique de négociation. Et donc, je serai la plus constructive possible dans le cadre de cette négociation.
Mais si en l'occurrence, ce n'est plus moi qui suis directement à la manœuvre, puisque c'est Philippe Henry qui a la présidence.
Un des outils sur lesquels je pense avoir compris que vous allez compter, ça va aussi être la fameuse fiscalité écologique, la fameuse, entre autres choses, pas seulement, mais la fameuse taxe carbone.
Comment et quand est-ce que ça va se concrétiser, ça, exactement ? Parce qu'il y a beaucoup de flou. On entend un peu tout et son contraire, selon qui en parle, quelle couleur politique en parle, par exemple.
Bon alors, vous aurez d'abord remarqué que ceux qui ont mis le sujet sur le tapis sont des adversaires politiques qui en font un enjeu.
Voilà, je trouve que le débat de la fiscalité environnementale mérite mieux que ça. D'abord, l'accord de majorité est clair.
Il va y avoir une réforme de la fiscalité vers une fiscalité plus verte. Ça, c'est acquis. Deux, cette réforme s'inscrit dans une réforme globale de la fiscalité,
puisqu'on sait qu'on a une des fiscalités les plus importantes, notamment sur l'emploi, etc.
Et donc, pour garantir un équilibre global de la fiscalité, pour ne pas augmenter la charge qui pèse sur les citoyens, ce sera dans un exercice d'équilibre global.
Donc, c'est mon collègue Van Peteghem qui est à la manœuvre. Donc, je ne vais pas, moi, sortir de cette mandature en ayant engrangé une fiscalité verte toute seule.
Donc, c'est vraiment lui qui est à la manœuvre. Donc ça, c'est le cadre qui est placé. À l'intérieur de cette réforme, évidemment, je participe aux discussions.
La question de la fiscalité environnementale, ce n'est pas que la taxe carbone. La fiscalité environnementale, elle peut être, on l'a dit, à travers, elle peut être punitive, mais elle peut être aussi incitative.
On peut aussi jouer sur une diminution de la TVA, sur les comportements les plus vertueux. Mais effectivement, la question du prix carbone, on ne va pas y échapper.
On ne va pas y échapper. C'est... Aujourd'hui, alors les premiers qui se sont élevés contre la taxe carbone, c'était la famille libérale, alors que c'est eux qui ont négocié l'accord.
Moi, je n'étais pas autour de la table. C'est Jean-Louis Boucher qui est monté contre cette taxe carbone. C'est le président de l'Open VLD.
C'est eux qui étaient autour de la table. Et dans l'accord de majorité, on évoque le principe du pollueur-payeur. Alors, ou alors, ils ont signé, enfin, ils ne savaient pas ce qu'ils signaient, etc.
Toujours est-il qu'ils évoquent effectivement la poche du citoyen. Mais moi, c'est pas à ça que je pense.
Aujourd'hui, penser qu'on ne paye pas collectivement déjà des choses pour lesquelles nous ne sommes pas responsables.
Je donne un exemple, quand on doit, par exemple, dépolluer un terrain, c'est la collectivité qui le paye, hein. C'est pas l'entreprise qui l'a pollué.
Et donc, il faut aujourd'hui qu'on fasse prendre à chacun sa part de responsabilité. Et l'enjeu de la fiscalité verte, c'est d'intégrer le coût environnemental.
Et donc aujourd'hui, le coût environnemental,
il se répercute dans la sécurité sociale, par exemple. Aujourd'hui, on connaît la qualité de notre air, on sait tout ce que ça a comme impact sur notre santé et on connaît le nombre de décès.
Donc, penser aujourd'hui que la pollution, les changements climatiques ne coûtent pas et que c'est la fiscalité verte qui va faire du mal, c'est une hérésie totale.
La fiscalité permettrait précisément de diminuer les coûts en matière de sécurité sociale, en matière de, pour ce qui concerne la mobilité, par exemple, la perte de temps dans les embouteillages, etc.
Donc, la question environnementale, la question de la fiscalité environnementale, ce n'est pas que la taxe carbone. Mais la taxe carbone, le cas échéant, permet d'intégrer le coût d'un produit ou d'un service.
Mais j'ajoute tout de suite qu'on ne le fait que s'il y a une alternative. Donc, si nous nous engageons
dans cette voie-là, l'idée est de faire en sorte qu'il y ait un choix qui soit plus vertueux, puisque l'objectif de la fiscalité environnementale, c'est le changement des comportements.
Et donc, alors, j'arrêterai là sur ce sujet-là, mais quand, sous le gouvernement Michel, ils ont décidé d'augmenter les accises sur le diesel, en disant que c'était une fiscalité verte.
Eh bien, je me suis opposée à cette augmentation. Tout le monde a été surpris. Je me suis opposée parce que dans le même temps le gouvernement Michel a fermé des gares dans des régions éloignées dans le Luxembourg ou en Flandre. De telle sorte que
c'était un win-win pour l'État. Ils ferment les gares, donc ils obligent les gens qui habitent dans des villages à devoir utiliser leur voiture pour aller chercher leur pain ou pour la moindre,
la moindre course à faire et donc à devoir remplir le réservoir et donc à, voilà, c'était jackpot pour le gouvernement à chacune des étapes.
Je pense qu'on ne peut augmenter les accises du diesel, par exemple, que s'il y a une offre de mobilité crédible à côté.
Et donc les choses vont de pair. C'est pour ça, effectivement, je clôturerai dessus,
que la réforme fiscale, elle se fera dans un cadre global pour qu'à chaque fois, on rééquilibre les choses et qu'on reste dans une justice sociale.
Alors, beaucoup de choses sur lesquelles j'ai envie de réagir. Mais quand on parle donc de réforme fiscale, quand on parle
d'économie à l'échelle du pays, un point où les libéraux et les écologistes divergent, mais totalement, c'est sur la question de la fameuse décroissance, puisque on parle de Georges-Louis Bouchez, il est loin d'être fan de l'idée.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui te paraît atteignable, réaliste un jour, sachant qu'on vit dans un pays de coalition, un pays où il faut faire des compromissions et où la famille verte est la seule à prôner cette idée ?
Alors, donc j'étais présidente de mon parti, j'ai encore en tête tous nos programmes, etc. Nulle part, les écologistes ont revendiqué la décroissance.
D'accord.
Vous le trouvez dans aucun de nos textes. Il y a effectivement des tenants de la décroissance chez Écolo.
OK.
Comme il y a des tenants de la décroissance qui ne sont pas chez Écolo. Donc, dans le projet politique, non. Voilà. Alors, c'est vrai qu'on défend une sobriété.
Enfin, je veux dire, on voit quand même nos consommations exploser, etc. Donc, ce que nous prenons, c'est une autre croissance.
Et donc la décroissance, moi, aujourd'hui, je refuse de me laisser piéger dans le débat public parce que ce sont des termes, on évoque décroissance, ça veut dire quoi ?
Surtout quand ce sont les libéraux qui l'utilisent. C'est le retour à la bougie, c'est vraiment s'habiller avec des peaux de bêtes, etc., etc.
Ici, je vais revenir. Ici, on vient de vivre une année douloureuse, avec le COVID.
Mais c'est une année, c'est une crise qui nous a mis face, de la manière la plus brutale qu'il soit, face à nos fragilités et face aux limites du modèle de la croissance à tout prix et de la globalisation.
Et l'exemple le plus criant, c'est celui des masques. Le monde entier avait les yeux tournés vers la Chine pour avoir ces masques.
On a vu des services secrets sur les tarmacs de nos aéroports qui venaient chercher pour leur population des masques. Ça, c'est la limite du modèle de globalisation et de croissance à tout va.
Et donc, c'est ce que nous dénonçons. Nous plaidons pour une relocalisation de notre économie à l'échelle européenne.
On plaide pour un ralentissement aussi des rythmes, que ce soit de la vie, du travail. Mais tout ça, ce n'est pas de la décroissance telle que les libéraux l'évoquent.
Et donc, c'est comme avec la taxe carbone, ce sont vraiment les totems qui décrédibilisent et qui délégitiment la parole des écologistes.
Mh. Et donc, juste pour revenir là-dessus, il y a certaines voix au sein du Parti écologiste qui prônent la décroissance, de même qu'on trouve aussi certaines voix qui se revendiquent comme étant anti-capitalistes.
Toi, personnellement, où est-ce que tu en es sur ces questions ?
Je crois pas que je suis une décroissante.
D'accord.
Je dis ça parce que j'ai des gens autour de moi qui le sont et que, voilà, je n'ai pas ce-
T'as pas de mépris par rapport à ça, mais tu ne l'es pas personnellement.
Oui, non, non, non, non, non. Je prône la sobriété et je prône, euh... Donc moi, je ne prône pas la croissance, je prône la prospérité partagée.
On pense que ce sont que des termes différents, alors que ce sont vraiment des réalités différentes. Donc moi, je pense qu'on peut continuer, qu'on peut consommer de manière responsable.
C'est pas décroissance. C'est se donner quelques principes de consommation. C'est-à-dire, moi, je refuse de, enfin, d'ailleurs, ça serait dans ma politique.
Il y a des produits que je n'achète pas, ou des produits que je privilégie parce que je sais qu'ils viennent de circuits dans lesquels les travailleurs sont respectés.
Là, je ne participe pas à la déforestation, je ne participe pas, etc. Donc c'est une autre consommation. Voilà.
Ça, je le prône, oui, et ça, je le revendique. C'est une autre consommation.
Oui. Et précisément sur la question du capitalisme et de l'anticapitalisme, je pose ces questions pour un petit peu revenir sur ces images qu'on accole sur le Parti écologiste, pour un petit peu nuancer ces a priori.
Alors, bon, capitalisme, enfin, je veux dire, d'abord, reconnaissons que même comme écologiste, enfin, je veux dire, on en a tous profité.
On l'a vu. Voilà. Et donc les choses-- Mais à un moment donné, on voit les excès, les limites de tous ces modèles, que ce soit le capitalisme, que ce soit le-
Néolibéralisme.
Comme le néolibéralisme, etc. Enfin, je veux dire, ou comme il y a des excès aussi dans l'écologie. Enfin, je veux dire, c'est pas le propre, euh...
Donc, je dis, on en a tous profité. Et en même temps, aujourd'hui, on mesure la responsabilité du capitalisme dans les écarts entre ceux qui vivent le mieux et ceux qui vivent le moins bien.
Et ils sont de plus en plus importants. Et ça, c'est pas acceptable. Voilà, donc oui, se dire anticapitaliste, c'est, c'est...
Comment c'est ? C'est un slogan.
Mh.
Donc, ouais, je me revendique comme écologiste avec tout ce que ça sous-entend par rapport au capitalisme. Donc une autre, la prospérité partagée, une autre consommation plus durable, dans un monde qui est régulé.
Enfin, c'est-à-dire que moi, je crois pas dans la main invisible du marché qui règle tout, mais je crois pas non plus dans la toute-puissance et la prédominance de l'État, par exemple.
Je pense que l'État est là pour placer un cadre bienveillant, pour garantir aux individus de pouvoir évoluer en toute liberté et en toute dignité.
Voilà, donc, je ne crois ni dans la main invisible ni dans l'État, mais un peu plus, je fais un peu plus confiance au public et donc j'ai envie de dire à l'État, à la main visible, ça, c'est sûr.
Mais alors, sur cette idée-là, on a justement appris il y a quelques jours, une dizaine de jours, que le président Biden avait comme ambition également une grande réforme fiscale.
Il présente ça comme étant un impôt mondial sur les entreprises, donc sur cette idée justement du pollueur-payeur, si j'ai bien compris.
Bah, moi, j'ai toujours défendu la progressivité. Et donc en effet, que la charge la plus importante pèse sur les épaules les plus larges.
Donc, que ce soit pour les entreprises ou pour les particuliers. Donc ça, je pense que c'est un enjeu fondamental d'équité, oui.
Alors, je suis curieuse de voir la suite-
Ouais, voilà, j'allais dire : Est-ce que tu penses que ça a une bonne chance de se réaliser ?
Bah écoute, c'est la première fois qu'un président l'annonce. Alors, voilà, aujourd'hui, c'est de l'annonce, on verra bien.
Mais à mon avis, quand on voit notamment les effets de la crise,
de la crise sanitaire, etc. Et où on voit que certaines multinationales n'ont fait que du profit sur le dos de cette crise, oui, y a quand même lieu de s'interroger et d'essayer de réformer un peu les choses, oui.
Mmm-hmm. Enfin, dernière question, donc, sur le climat. La question du nucléaire, puisque on a beaucoup parlé de cette question de sortie du nucléaire en Belgique.
Je vais notamment en parler, j'espère, dans quelques semaines avec Jean-Marc Jancovici. Est-ce qu'Écolo prône absolument, définitivement, inévitablement une sortie du nucléaire en Belgique ou pas ?
Parce qu'on a entendu des choses un petit peu contradictoires à ce sujet.
Alors, des choses contradictoires, à mon avis, pas dans le chef d'Écolo. Dans le débat public, sans doute, mais pas dans le chef d'Écolo.
Donc peut-être deux choses. D'abord, y a pas qu'Écolo. Y avait un accord en 2003 entre acteurs politiques pour sortir et puis cette fois-ci pour confirmer.
Et à chaque fois, ça a été parfois avec les mêmes acteurs politiques, parfois pas. Et donc dans l'ensemble, tous à un moment donné se sont prononcés pour la prolongation.
Ça, c'est un. Deux, il se trouve qu'en 2003, nous étions au gouvernement quand cet engagement a été pris, il n'a pas été respecté.
Donc aujourd'hui, on se retrouve de nouveau dans un gouvernement et y a deux agendas, j'ai envie de dire, qui se télescopent.
Y a l'agenda climatique, mais y a l'agenda de sortie du nucléaire qu'on veut faire aboutir. Ça, c'est vrai. Alors aujourd'hui, dans le-- Mais donc, l'accord est clair aussi, cette sortie est très, est balisée.
C'est-à-dire, on ne prendra aucun risque en matière de sécurité d'approvisionnement. Et donc, y a une clause au rendez-vous pour ma collègue Tinne Van der Straeten qui est en novembre,
qui, suite à un appel, va voir ce qui est sur la table,
qui permettrait ou pas d'envisager la sortie de tout le nucléaire, c'est-à-dire singulièrement de deux centrales.
Parce que sur toutes les autres, y a aucune discussion. Donc, il n'y aura pas de risque d'approvisionnement.
Le calcul sera fait. Ça, c'est un. Donc, voilà, ceux qui pensent que les écologistes sont irresponsables n'ont jamais lu l'accord de majorité.
Et puis, je crois que c'est aussi un signal pour dire quand les politiques prennent un engagement, ils le tiennent.
Je veux di-- C'est un engagement qui a été pris en 2003. Je vois pas ce qu'il y a de honteux à vouloir respecter cet engagement.
Alors aujourd'hui, on trouve dans le débat climatique des gens qui ne se sont jamais préoccupés du climat,
mais qui sont des lobbyistes pro-nucléaires et qui aujourd'hui utilisent l'agenda climatique pour contrer cette volonté de fermeture.
Et ça brouille tous les messages. Alors moi, je vais être claire. La fermeture des centrales, elle s'inscrit dans une volonté historique, de sécurité aussi.
On n'a toujours pas de réponse sur la gestion des déchets, par exemple. Alors, on dit que la-- D'abord, et économiquement,
les centrales sont tellement vieilles, fissurées, etc., que, d'abord, vous ne trouvez plus l'assurance pour assurer le risque de ces centrales.
Les énergies renouvelables, le coût des énergies renouvelables diminue de telle sorte qu'aujourd'hui, économiquement, le choix du nucléaire est le moins intéressant et le moins rentable.
Ça, c'est un. Donc économiquement, le meilleur choix est la sortie. Deux, tant qu'on ne donnait pas ce signal-là, les investisseurs n'ont pas investi dans le renouvelable.
Aujourd'hui, le signal, il est clair. Il est : ça va être terminé, donc investissez en masse. Or, on a pris tellement de retard qu'il a fallu une étape intermédiaire,
qui est celle des centrales au gaz qui vont, elles, permettre
de garantir cet approvisionnement
en électricité.
Et donc, voilà, le récit global est brouillé, dans le débat sur le climat par des tenants du nucléaire. Alors moi, je suis pas une-- Sur ce dossier-là, alors c'est vrai qu'on dit que je suis une dogmatique, etc.
Sur ce dossier-là,
je suis sans doute la moins dogmatique,
mais la vérité a ses droits.
Et donc ce sont deux dossiers différents, deux agendas différents que les négociateurs ont choisi de mettre en même temps dans un accord de majorité, et donc qui est bien calibré, qui est bien cadré,
de telle sorte qu'on ne mette pas en péril la sécurité d'approvisionnement.
Les centrales au gaz, contrairement à ce qui est dit dans le débat public, ne deviennent pas notre source d'électricité.
Les centrales au gaz sont là par sécurité. On sait que les centrales à gaz sont plus, comment, sont plus souples,
et donc on peut couper, rallumer, enfin voilà, dans le jeu des besoins en provisions, etc.
C'est plus souple qu'une centrale nucléaire et ça permet de répondre effectivement à l'investissement massif qui va devoir être fait, mais qui va être par étapes.
Et donc tant que les investissements ne sont pas suffisants pour garantir le même approvisionnement que ce que les centrales font, eh bien, on fera appel aux centrales à gaz.
Mais c'est une étape intermédiaire, ce n'est qu'une étape intermédiaire.
Donc, tu te décris comme quelqu'un qui n'est pas forcément dogmatique et qui peut être en réflexion sur beaucoup de questions au sujet, donc, de l'environnement.
Mais justement, pourquoi toi, qui doutes, qui remets les choses en question plutôt que quelqu'un, justement, de très passionnel, très dogmatique ?
Alors, quand j'ai dit que c'était pas dogmatique, c'est sur la question du nucléaire. Je pense que, pff, bon, je peux assumer cette question-là sur mon féminisme ou sur mon droit de l'hommisme, pour le dire, enfin voilà.
Mais c'est vrai que même là, j'ai des principes, mais je me force à n'avoir aucune certitude et à m'interroger tout le temps.
C'est vrai que les gens ont été surpris que j'accepte ce ministère puisque, donc moi, je dis toujours : Un environnementaliste n'est pas spécialement écologiste.
L'inverse n'est pas vrai. Et donc moi, on m'a connue sur des enjeux d'écologie politique au sens large, donc sur la justice, etc., etc.
Moins sur les matières vertes. Et donc quand j'ai accepté de monter, ça a été la surprise de tout le monde. J'ai quand même été présidente d'Écolo, donc...
Mais c'est vrai que si j'ai accepté, c'est parce que précisément, je voulais avoir une approche écologiste et pas seulement environnementale de ce département.
Et donc dès le départ, j'ai dit à mes équipes, et j'ai d'ailleurs rédigé une note d'intention dans ce sens, je peux te la donner si tu veux, où je disais que justice sociale et justice environnementale sont liées.
Je souhaitais aujourd'hui que les experts, que l'administration, que dans le débat public, que mes collègues, se rendent compte que
la question environnementale n'est pas une question de niche réservée à certains au détriment d'autres.
Voilà. Et ça, je me suis dit que c'est ce que je pouvais apporter à ce département-ci, de spécifique. Et donc, oui.
Et donc aujourd'hui, quand on discute de la fiscalité, j'ai eu une réunion passionnante avec la Fédération des associations qui luttent contre la pauvreté, c'était les Bruxellois, les Wallons et les Flamands.
Je discutais par exemple avec Christine Mahy sur la question précisément de la taxe carbone, sur la question aussi de comment aujourd'hui démocratiser le débat climatique, de telle sorte que tout le monde se sente concerné.
Comment réfléchir nos politiques de transition de telle sorte que personne ne se sente lésé. Voilà, ça, je pense que ce sont des éléments que j'amène à partir de ce département
qu'un autre n'aurait pas amené, qui aurait fait très bien aussi sans doute, mais ça, c'est la spécificité.
C'était le challenge que je me suis donné. Je souhaitais démocratiser le débat climatique et je souhaitais aussi que la transition soit acceptée et soit légitime aux yeux du plus grand nombre. Voilà.
Zakia, est-ce que tu as entendu parler du concept de pétro-masculinité ?
Vaguement.
C'est simplement ce concept de l'homme qui définit sa masculinité par sa grosse bagnole bien polluante-
Oui, d'accord.
Qui crache de la fumée noire. À tes yeux, est-ce que c'est concret ? Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que tu observes beaucoup ?
C'est dans l'opposition aux idées écologistes, un rapport en direct à la masculinité.
Oui, 'fin, on a eu dernièrement un président de parti qui donnait une interview et on était dans le cliché le plus sexiste-
Mh.
Et le plus pétro-masculiniste, voilà. Donc oui, oui, ça, ce sont encore des-- Je veux dire, ce sont des réali-- C'est même pas des clichés.
C'est une réalité que je pensais dépasser chez les hommes de ma génération. Et voilà, j'ai été forcée de constater que c'était pas le cas.
Et donc, exister un peu ça, c'est aussi un des excès de notre société de surconsommation. C'est exister à travers ce qu'on consomme.
Une grosse bagnole, une grosse montre, une grosse chaîne, une grosse maison, etc., etc. Voilà, tout ça fait un tout.
'Fin, alors, en fait, je ne sais même pas très bien à quelle interview tu fais référence. Tu parles à Bart De Wever ou tu penses à-
Non, à Georges-Louis Bouchez.
Ah bah voilà.
Donc, il donnait une interview sur une belle voiture, il y a-- une voiture de course.
Ah oui, d'accord, OK.
Voilà.
J'avais loupé ça.
Il y a quinze jours, je pense.
D'accord.
Et voilà. Donc, bref.
OK, OK. Voilà. Mais donc, c'était donc pour faire la transition sur la question plutôt liée au féminisme, puisque ce sont, voilà, des sujets qui t'intéressent également.
Tu as quitté Twitter pendant un temps. Est-ce qu'on peut en parler ? Est-ce que-
Oui.
'Fin, voilà, tu es loin d'être la seule. On pense parmi les amis du podcast, on pense par exemple à Marie Peltier, à Florence Hainaut ou à Myriam Leroy.
Qu'est-ce qui avait amené chez toi cette décision ? Et qu'est-ce qui t'a amené à y revenir ?
Est-ce qu'il y a un lien avec le féminisme ?
Alors, je pense que oui, il y a un lien. Bon, d'abord, 'fin, on le voit, hein, avec les noms que tu cites. C'est quand même-
Bien sûr.
...tous les mêmes profils. 'Fin, des femmes qui s'assument, qui portent une voix claire, qui baissent pas les yeux et qui ne rasent pas les murs, quoi.
Et Twitter, les réseaux sociaux en général, mais ici en l'occurrence Twitter, grâce à l'anonymat, permet à tous les frustrés de la Terre de venir se défouler, hein. Et-
Ils sont pas nécessairement anonymes, d'ailleurs.
Non, non, non, mais...
J'ai en tête quelques profils bien connus du Twitter belge.
Absolument. Oui, oui, tout à fait. Mais bon, si ça s'était arrêté à eux, c'est pas grave.
Oui.
Je veux dire, quand ça devient-- Je veux dire, quand c'est une armée, mais 'fin, il faut m'imaginer qu'à un moment donné, moi, je n'arrivais plus à suivre.
Et c'est beaucoup des trolls, comme on les appelle-
Oui.
...mais qui sont relayés par des profils non anonymes et inversement, ou ces trolls qui relayent des propos de certains non anonymes, etc.
Et ça commence à faire nombre. Mais dans le nombre, il y en a très peu qui assument, hein, et donc ils sont quand même, ce sont des anonymes.
Et alors, on a quelques figures, moi, j'ai pas envie de les citer, mais tout le monde aura compris.
C'est une si bonne idée, de pas les citer.
Mais voilà, donc... Et donc, ce qui a été très-- À un moment donné, les attaques ne correspondent à rien.
'Fin, je veux dire, ça devient du délire, quoi.
Mh.
Alors moi-
Une construction de réalité, quoi, un truc, un univers parallèle.
C'est-à-dire que moi, je cumule, dans leur monde, hein, deux tares. Non seulement je suis une femme, mais en plus, je suis de confession musulmane.
Ah, ah d'accord, OK.
Oui, oui. Non, non. Et donc là, parce que ça fait beaucoup. 'Fin, je veux dire, et comme je suis de confession musulmane, je suis suspecte.
Je ne pouvais rien dire. Alors parfois, je pouvais dire la même chose que Florence, ou que Marie, etc. Elles, on les attaquait comme femmes.
Moi, c'était le grand remplacement. Voilà, c'est assez hallucinant, quoi. Et puis alors parfois venait se greffer effectivement la question de femme.
Parce que moi, plusieurs fois sur des prises de-- quand j'étais présidente, sur des prises de paroles très fortes qui plaisaient pas aux conservateurs de droite,
certains interpellaient Jean-Michel, Jean-Marc, Patrick, en disant : « Mais qu'est-ce que vous faites ?
Ça va ou quoi ? » Moi, j'ai jamais entendu quelqu'un qui m'interpellait en disant : « Mais tu as entendu ce que tes collègues viennent de dire ?
Tu te remettrais pas à leur place. » Ça, ce sont des choses que j'ai vécues et que je n'imaginais même pas, de telle sorte qu'à la fin de ma présidence,
à la fin de ma présidence, oui, j'ai été me faire tatouer.
Voilà, tu le vois là.
Ah ouais.
Le symbole des féministes, voilà.
D'accord.
Tellement c'était... Je veux dire, je n'ai... et le pire, c'est que j'ai été confrontée à la violence sexiste et raciste la plus forte dans les milieux qui s'en défendent.
Et à certains niveaux de, alors pas de pouvoir, mais d'influence, hein.
Et donc ça, c'est assez... ça m'avait-- parce que bon, je suis militante antiraciste et féministe de longue date, donc je connais la réalité patriarcale de notre société, etc., etc.
Mais ce qui a été le plus dur à vivre, c'est de voir que ceux qui s'en défendent, alors tout le monde s'en défend, mais ceux-là non seulement s'en défendent, mais en plus se disent des alliés de la cause féministe, etc., etc.
Et donc ça a été une double violence. Le pro-, 'fin, quand il n'était pas caché, quand c'était pas des anonymes, je veux dire, le profil de certains, je trouve, double la violence du propos.
C'est-à-dire ?
Parce que ce sont des démocrates, ce sont des... Enfin, voilà. Et donc c'est, ça devient incompréhensible et ça, voilà, et ça fait boule de neige, quoi.
C'est relayé par des... comment on parle des... 'Fin, ça, je sais pas comment l'exprimer.
Tellement ça m'a dépassée à un moment donné. Voilà, ça m'a dépassée. Alors ça m'a dépassée, donc j'ai voulu arrêter aussi pour sauver ma santé mentale.
Et puis je suis revenue, mais de manière totalement différente, etc. Et je me rends compte que ça a laissé des traces. Vraiment.
Et ça m'énerve, quoi. Je n'ai pas imaginé, vraiment. C'est... Oui, quand parfois j'ai envie de tweeter un truc, je me dis : Ah non, j'ai pas envie de me prendre une, truc, donc je le fais pas.
Alors que le propos est important pour moi en tout cas.
Mh.
Et je me dis : Ben donc, ils ont gagné en fait. C'est une voix qu'on n'entend plus. Et avec ça, je me suis pas encore réconciliée, j'arrive pas encore à, voilà, j'arrive pas encore à être dans le même...
Bon alors aujourd'hui, je suis ministre, je suis pas présidente de parti, etc., etc. Il y a plein de choses différentes.
Mais quand même, ça m'a marquée plus que je ne le pensais et plus que je ne le voudrais.
Oui. Et donc je reviens sur ton tatouage. Tu aurais tendance à dire que ton séjour malheureux sur Twitter t'a radicalisée dans tes idées ?
T'as renforcé tes idées féministes ?
Renforcé-
Parce que pendant tout un temps, ta bio sur Twitter, c'était : Féministe radicale assumée, je pense.
Oui. Alors, j'aurais pu le laisser, mais ici, comme j'ai mis mon titre de ministre et que c'est, 'fin, je peux pas choisir le titre et qu'en plus, je suis au fédéral, donc je vais le mettre en néerlandais.
Ouais.
Et donc je continue. Ça, je le cache pas.
D'accord.
Oui, ça, je n'ai aucun problème avec ça. Ici, c'est, je-- quand je serai plus ministre, je remettrai ça.
C'est ça.
Et plus que jamais d'ailleurs. En fait, au début de Twitter, c'était féministe, je ne sais plus. Et puis ça a évolué.
C'est devenu féministe radicale et puis féministe radicale assumée. Et donc voilà, si j'étais pas devenue ministre, je sais pas ce que j'aurais encore accolé.
C'est-à-dire sur le fond, j'ai toujours été une féministe. Ici, la radicalité, elle est dans, oui, le fait de ne plus rien laisser passer.
Voilà. Quand... j'essaie de trouver un exemple, hein. 'Fin ici, la dernière histoire qu'on a eue avec Charles Michel et von der Leyen.
Pour moi, c'est vrai que moi, j'étais plus-- 'Fin, d'Erdogan, j'attends rien de ce point de vue-là. Donc moi, j'étais-
Oui.
Plus frappée ou choquée par l'attitude de Charles Michel. Et puis après, par l'argument de la défense.
Le premier, c'était, il pleurait sur son sort. Enfin, je veux dire, alors voilà, en disant : Je suis désolé, j'ai mal dormi.
Oui, mais 'fin, en attendant, et sur l'enjeu en tant que tel, vous dites quoi ?
Mh.
'Fin voilà. Et donc oui, pour moi, y a plus de blague sexiste qui est drôle, non. Ça véhicule des clichés, ça véhicule...
'Fin voilà. Donc dans ce sens-là, en effet, je me suis sans doute radicalisée, oui.
Oui. Donc-
Et peut-être terminer là-dessus.
Oui.
Parce que moi, je pense que y a rien de léger, dans le sens où ce sont les mots qui construisent notre pensée et notre univers mental.
Et donc, parfois, une bête blague potache qui n'a l'air de rien ancre dans notre univers mental et symbolique des choses au-delà de la blague.
Et ça, il faut le mesurer. Et voilà. Et donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a des choses qui me feront jamais rire.
Bien sûr, bien sûr. Dans les éléments de langage qu'on retrouve souvent donc chez ces trolls-là, chez ces personnes-là qui t'emmerdaient sur Twitter, le mythe du fameux islamo-gauchisme.
Oui, oui.
D'où est-ce que ça vient ?
Aucune idée. 'Fin, pendant que tu posais la question, je vais donner l'exemple de Finkielkraut qui dit : À quoi on reconnaît un islamo-gauchiste ?
Parce qu'il s'en défend. Enfin, je veux dire, c'est rigolo, quoi, c'est comme les islamophobes en fait. Voilà. J'avais envie de dire ça.
C'est vrai.
Alors, je ne sais pas d'où ça vient. Je ne sais pas. Alors, le pire dans le débat... Alors, il y a évidemment les extrêmes, hein.
'Fin, je veux dire, il y a ceux avec qui, des islamophobes-
On peut même pas-
Avec qui tu discutes jamais, etc. Puis, et de l'autre côté aussi, des gens qui ont pour projet politique l'islam, etc.
C'est vrai aussi, mais c'est pas la grande majorité, ni dans un extrême ni dans l'autre. Et entre les deux, je pense qu'il y a une crainte légitime et qui peut s'exprimer autrement que par la violence et des accusations.
Je veux dire, moi, je m'interroge beaucoup. Je fais l'objet d'attaques de cette fameuse observatoire dont j'avais jamais entendu parler.
Je connais même pas cette-
Oui.
La dame qui est derrière, etc. Donc je-
L'Observatoire des-
Voilà.
L'Observatoire des fondamentalismes religieux.
Voilà, c'est ça. Donc 'fin, je connais même pas, donc je sais même pas le nom. Voilà. Et donc régulièrement, je fais l'objet d'attaques et je comprends rien.
Vraiment, je n'y comprends rien. Mais je sais, j'essaie de comprendre et je me dis : Mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière ?
Il y a, à mon avis, il y a une souffrance ou il y a une inquiétude légitime.
Mh.
OK, mais alors parlons-en. Peut-être que j'ai la même inquiétude et peut-être que j'ai la même... 'Fin voilà. Et donc cette confrontation, elle est insupportable.
Et alors, avec les réseaux sociaux, parce qu'évidemment, l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux a d'autres objectifs, hein, de notoriété, de je sais pas quoi, je sais pas quoi.
Et donc des débats fondamentaux sont mis à mal ou en tout cas, la sérénité nécessaire à certains débats est mise à mal par d'autres enjeux sur les réseaux sociaux.
Je sais pas si je me fais comprendre. Je vais peut-être reprendre mon raisonnement au début. Moi, je sais que j'ai utilisé Twitter, je suis devenue présidente de parti, j'étais inconnue dans le sérail politique.
Et donc j'ai utilisé Twi-- De manière, enfin sciemment, Twitter avec des phrases chocs, hein. Et c'est comme ça que j'attirais l'attention des journalistes, des politiques.
OK.
Mais je l'ai fait sur des formules par rapport à des politiques, pas par rapport à des individus. J'ai jamais attaqué quelqu'un, ou alors qu'on me sorte un tweet.
Mais donc oui, j'ai attaqué des politiques avec des formules chocs.
Mh. Chose que tu ne ferais plus aujourd'hui, si j'ai bien compris.
C'est-à-dire oui, parce que ça a suscité des réactions où on m'a prêté des intentions qui n'étaient pas les miennes.
Oui.
Voilà. Et donc comme je ne suis pas responsable de la manière dont tu vas recevoir les messages que je donne, voilà.
Donc, je ne veux plus prendre ce risque-là. Ça m'a coûté beaucoup, à moi, et je pense que parfois, j'ai fait du mal sans le vouloir, donc je ne le ferai plus.
Mais je suis toujours... Enfin, moi, je doute beaucoup, hein. Et donc je te dis ça et tout de suite après, je me dis : et en même temps, c'est la victoire de ceux qui veulent pas qu'une voix comme la mienne s'exprime.
Alors, elle est où ? La balance, elle est où ? Et la, voilà, l'équilibre, il est où ? Ben, je crois que je l'ai pas encore trouvé puisque, ici, je suis plus dans une com institutionnelle, etc.
J'écris beaucoup. Et donc on verra, on verra ce que ça donne. Mais c'est clair que l'équilibre, je l'ai pas encore trouvé sur les réseaux sociaux.
Et en revenant, moi, j'ai d'emblée bloqué un certain nombre de comptes que j'identifiais comme étant, voilà. Mais malgré ça, parfois, on m'envoie des captures d'écran.
Je veux dire, je reste l'attention de certains, enfin, qui, bon, je trouve qu'ils m'accordent plus d'attention que je n'en mérite.
Ouais, ouais.
Ils ont une idée de moi plus haute que moi-même, à mon avis.
Ce qui était très intéressant quand on échangeait à ce sujet avec Marie Peltier et Florence Hainaut en septembre dernier, c'était de constater que
Twitter avait, en particulier Twitter, mais les réseaux sociaux de manière générale, avaient cet effet de faire enfler la construction de réalité.
Et donc ces personnes qui, donc sur Twitter, te détestent, sont persuadées que parce qu'ils ont lu l'article de blog-
Absolument.
...de tel influenceur, etc., sont persuadés, croient dur comme fer que tu as des liens avec Daesh, que ceci, que cela, que voilà.
Oui, oui, tout à fait.
Et donc ça, c'est un effet nauséabond des réseaux sociaux.
Absolument.
Clairement.
Oui, oui, ça, je reprends à mon compte à deux cents pour cent. C'est ce que je disais quand je disais entre les extrêmes et puis entre les deux, il y a des gens qui s'interrogent légitimement, etc.
Mais y a pas d'espace pour discuter. Moi, j'ai lu des trucs sur moi, je tombais des nues. Et je me dis : Mais attendez, moi, je dirais ça de quelqu'un, moi-même, j'aurais peur.
Et alors, on est coincé,
on est coincé là-dedans sans-- et c'est pour ça que j'ai quitté. Parce qu'à un moment donné, l'image que j'avais, c'est, tu sais, t'es dans une boîte ou dans une pièce où il y a pas de porte et pas de fenêtre et tu cherches partout.
Et alors hop, j'ai coupé. Et du coup, ça m'a permis aussi de voir que ouf, Twitter n'est pas le monde, quoi. Je veux dire, non seulement ça m'a pas manqué, mais en plus, dans mon quotidien, personne ne parlait de Twitter, quoi.
Ça t'a pas manqué, mais tu es revenue.
Oui, mais aujourd'hui, je sais que ce que je vois là, ça concerne que ce qu'il y a là.
Oui.
Et que j'ai tout un espace de vie en vrai qui est totalement, limite, qui est totalement... Mais je vois bien, vraisemblablement, j'ai bloqué les bons comptes.
Puisqu'ils continuent ce qu'ils veulent sans moi et donc ça ne m'affecte pas, ça ne me, voilà.
Mh, mh. Très bien. Dans le jeu des sept familles, tu appartiens plutôt à quelle famille de féministes ? Parce que j'ai écouté une interview de toi où tu te présentes à la fois comme universaliste et comme intersectionnelle.
Ce qui est intéressant à noter, je trouve, parce que généralement, c'est soit l'un, soit l'autre et on se crêpe le chignon très très fort.
Non, non, non, non. Je pense qu'il y a une évolution. Enfin, je veux dire, intersectionnelle, ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça veut dire que, donc, je veux dire, je le vis moi-même.
Je sais que, l'intersectionnalité, c'est à un moment donné, un certain public de femmes vit un certain nombre de discriminations de différents ordres et elles sont à l'intersection de ces différentes.
C'est ça en fait l'intersectionnalité. Quand on est femme de la diversité, des milieux populaires, etc., etc.
Et donc ça, l'intersectionnalité, c'est prendre en compte dans le vécu de la femme et dans les discriminations qu'elle vit, cet ensemble d'éléments.
Ça, c'est un. Mais je reste universaliste et je me rends-- c'est-à-dire que je ne... Moi, je suis une militante antiraciste des années quatre-vingt, nonante.
Donc moi, je ne suis pas de ceux qui revendiquent le mot racisée. Moi, je me présente pas comme une racisée, ça me donne des boutons.
Oui, oui.
Pourquoi ? D'abord parce que c'est-- ici, on voit bien que c'est la nouvelle génération qui l'utilise, mais c'est la nouvelle génération qui fait référence aux États-Unis hein.
Alors que moi, le mot race est plus lié à l'histoire européenne et on a vu tout ce que ça a, enfin, ce que ça impliquait, le mot race, etc.
Donc sur le fond, je pense que les préoccupations des jeunes générations, voilà, qui utilisent ce lexique-là, etc., sont les mêmes que moi.
Elles utilisent un autre lexique qui n'est pas le mien. Moi, voilà, je n'arrive pas et je ne...
Tu parles des jeunes générations. Tu n'es pas beaucoup plus âgée, par exemple, que Rokhaya Diallo, qu'on a reçue dans ce podcast-
Oui, oui
...qui tient très fort ce discours. Donc est-ce que c'est vraiment spécifique aux jeunes ?
Mais c'est-à-dire que Rokhaya Diallo est noire.
Et donc le récit de la discrimination et donc la référence qu'elle fait à ces termes-là fait encore plus de sens pour elle, parce que ce sont-- alors ça, c'est une amie, ce que je fais, on est amies hein, je connais bien Rokhaya.
Et donc tous ces mouvements aux États-Unis de libération des femmes, mais aussi des Noirs, évidemment, qu'elle arrive à s'en, enfin-
Elle s'identifie à ça
...elle a une autre histoire. Oui, elle a une autre histoire que la mienne. Donc c'est pour ça, moi, je l'utilise pas pour moi, mais je ne crie pas au scandale quand d'autres l'utilisent.
Je veux dire, c'est nuancé, c'est différent.
Alors c'est génial parce que-
Je me rappelle une discussion avec Rokhaya
...on est dans une situation où c'est moi, l'homme blanc, qui vais défendre le mot racisée et c'est toi qui vas le condamner.
Moi, je le condamne pas, je l'utilise pas.
D'accord.
C'est pas la même chose hein. Non, non, non, non. C'est pour ça que je dis : je ne l'utilise pas pour moi, mais je ne suis pas de ceux qui crient au loup quand les autres l'utilisent.
Non, non, non, non, je ne le condamne pas.
Ok.
Ça participe de, enfin voilà, ce n'est pas dans mon histoire militante et je ne me reconnais pas dedans parce que moi, précisément, je suis de la génération antiraciste qui disait : les races n'existent pas.
Alors ici, on sait ce que ça met derrière, quand ils l'utilisent, ce que ça met derrière. Mais ça met derrière des concepts qui viennent des États-Unis, pas de mon... Enfin voilà.
Mais donc c'est l'idée de dire que les races n'existent pas en tant que réalité biologique, scientifique, mais par contre, la réalité, la construction sociale, le fait d'être-
Absolument
...discriminé, d'évoluer dans des sphères différentes-
Ça, c'est évident
...selon son origine
C'est pour ça que je dis-
Mais donc le fait d'être racisé existe alors.
Mais donc c'est ce que je te disais. Mais donc c'est ce que je te disais quand je dis : la réalité de ce qu'on dénonce est la même
Oui
Ce sont les mots qu'on met dessus qui est différent. Voilà. Et donc, c'est... Moi, je peux pas le dire autrement.
Le mot en tant que tel, je n'arrive pas. Voilà. Mais je mène les mêmes combats que Rokhaya, que Raja, que Margot, qui, eux, utilisent très facilement ce vocabulaire.
Donc, je ne remets pas en question le combat qui est derrière, c'est le même que le mien.
Mh.
Mais voilà, je n'arrive pas. Et donc, sur l'universalisme, moi, j'ai eu une discussion très très intéressante avec des jeunes féministes de mémoire coloniale, hein.
On avait un échange et effectivement, elles revendiquaient, par exemple, des espaces non mixtes, mais non mixtes du point de vue de l'origine aussi.
Voilà. Moi, j'ai toujours défendu les espaces non mixtes. On sait que la parole de la femme est plus libre quand, voilà, on est entre femmes.
On le voit aussi, il y a plusieurs expériences qui ont été faites dans les écoles, hein, dans des classes mixtes et dans des classes non mixtes.
On voit les attitudes et les prises de parole différenciées, etc. Donc tout ça est scientifiquement documenté, etc.
Et alors, donc, elles défendaient, je pense que c'était-- enfin des réunions entre jeunes femmes de la diaspora, de la diaspora africaine.
Et là, ça, c'est quelque chose, c'est une étape qui aujourd'hui m'échappe encore. Et de nouveau, je me bats pas contre, hein, je le dis, mais c'est quelque chose.
C'est-à-dire que je me rappelle des exemples que Rokhaya me donnait où elle me disait : « Mais tu sais, Zakia, quand toi, tu te promènes...
» Enfin, il y a un vécu que tu ne partages pas avec moi. Ça, je peux l'entendre.
Elle me dit : « Tu sais, quand tu te promènes en rue, t'as envie d'aller chez le coiffeur ou t'acheter une paire de lunettes et que tu rentres, t'as pas de problème, quoi.
» Elle dit : « Moi, avec par exemple, l'inclinaison de mon nez, etc., je peux rentrer chez aucun opticien parce que c'est pas pensé pour nous.
» Et c'est vrai.
Mh. Même chose pour les coiffeurs avec les cheveux crépus, etc.
Tout, absolument. Ou alors, elle me dit : « Quand je vais sur un plateau télé, je dois amener mon maquillage. » Et je veux dire, tout ça, comment est-ce qu'on peut le nier ?
Je veux dire, c'est sa réalité, mais bien sûr, je peux. Mais une fois que je l'ai entendu, je peux porter le combat au même titre qu'elle, il me semble. Voilà.
Bien sûr.
Ça, c'est une conviction que j'ai. Et donc c'est là où moi, je n'arrive pas à essayer de ce point de vue-là où...
Et en même temps, enfin, c'est pour ça que je dis, moi, j'ai aucune certitude, hein, je doute beaucoup et je continue à,
à revendiquer l'universalité, même si, en effet, je constate aussi que le combat féministe universel, il a été porté que par une catégorie de femmes, hein, des femmes blanches, etc., etc.
Bon. Et en même temps, moi, je refuse de dire, par exemple, que le combat antiraciste doit être porté que par des gens discriminés.
Je crois pas. Moi, je pense, par exemple, à une militante comme Zoé Jenou. Moi, je refuse qu'on lui retire la légitimité de ce combat.
Elle a été de ce combat-là bien avant certains de la diversité, quoi. Donc c'est là où je nuance les choses et où je-
Tu entends certaines voix qui voudraient lui retirer-
Non, c'est pas ce que je veux dire. Ce que je veux dire, c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui est investi dans la communauté.
Ouais.
Et selon certains discours, on dit : « Il faut être discriminé pour porter le combat. »
Mh.
Je prends pas par hasard cet exemple-là pour dire voilà en fait ce que ça veut dire. Ça veut dire que si le combat antiraciste-
Ouais, d'accord.
Doit être porté par des gens discriminés, des gens comme Zoé Jenou, qui ont été de ce combat à la première heure et avant que certains aujourd'hui qui revendiquent de porter plus que d'autres le combat.
Voilà. Donc, je suis nuancée et je suis inquiète. Je suis inquiète parce que les divisions, que ce soit dans le mouvement féministe ou dans le mouvement raciste, ne sert que les dominants.
Voilà. Pendant que nous, femmes de la diversité, hommes ou femmes de la diversité, etc., nous nous divisons,
eh bien, c'est les autres, les dominants, pour évoquer, hein, pour utiliser un terme sociologique que Bourdieu affectionnait, eh bien voilà, ils nous regardent, nous, les dominés, nous battre entre nous, quoi.
Mh.
Ça ne sert la cause de personne chez les dominés pour rester dans le lexique de Bourdieu.
C'est intéressant parce que j'écoute donc son discours et je cherche les éléments universalistes dans ce que tu dis.
Mh.
Et par exemple, le fameux cas des réunions mixtes ou non mixtes-
C'est pour moi ce qui illustre le mieux l'emblème de l'universalisme à la française, c'est-à-dire, ben, on déteste en théorie les réunions non mixtes quand on est universaliste.
Et toi, tu me dis le contraire.
Pour moi, le féminisme universaliste, c'est un féminisme qui se préoccupe de la situation des femmes, quelle qu'elle soit, qu'elle porte le voile ou pas-
Mh.
Qu'elle soit des pays du Nord ou du Sud. Le féminisme universaliste,
ça n'interroge pas les hommes. Le féminisme universaliste, c'est la question de l'égalité, hein, la question du patriarcat et c'est la question de la situation des femmes.
Et mon universalité, elle est : mon féminisme, il prévaut avant tout autre combat.
C'est-à-dire, on voit chez certains féminismes, par exemple, leur combat,
leur combat, j'allais dire pour la laïcité, non, parce que je,
leur combat laïcard, et c'est pas péjoratif, mais je veux dire, ou leur combat pour une laïcité, mais la laïcité comme un dogme, parfois, prend le pas, à mon avis, sur le combat féministe.
D'accord.
Puisque du coup, ces femmes-là, on les voit s'allier, on les voit être les alliées d'hommes non féministes plutôt que de se préoccuper de l'effet sur les femmes.
Donc moi, mon combat universaliste, c'est d'avoir comme priorité les femmes et leur traitement digne et leur traitement égalitaire et équitable.
Il est là, mon universalisme.
Tu as en tête des exemples de femmes féministes qui-
Moi, je pense à Badinter.
Oui, Badinter-
Vraiment, moi je-
Nadia Geerts, ce genre de personnes.
Comment ?
Nadia Geerts.
Ben Nadia Geerts ne se revendique pas comme féministe, je crois. Donc...
Si, si, si.
Je l'ai entendu dernièrement.
Elle est venue dans ce podcast.
Ah voilà, c'est ça.
Bon OK.
C'est-à-dire sur l'universalisme-
Ouais.
Je ne voudrais pas qu'on dise que le combat de Nadia Geerts est universaliste et pas le mien parce que je défends le droit individuel et privé des femmes de porter le voile.
Voilà. Donc moi, l'universalisme, c'est effectivement-
Oui, vous avez des définitions très différentes.
Vraisemblablement.
Ça, c'est très clair.
Vraisemblablement, vraisemblablement.
Ouais, ouais. Et, même moi, je dois dire que j'ai pas non plus cette même définition de l'universalisme que toi, je pense.
Ouais, mais donc c'est pour ça que je dis, moi, je n'ai aucune certitude-
Ouais.
Et je n'ai aucune, je me pose beaucoup de questions et surtout, j'ai pas envie... Alors, voilà, ceux qui me connaissent savent que je déteste qu'on m'accole une étiquette.
Et donc je me suis inventé sans doute ma propre,
ma propre étiquette d'universaliste. Parce que si le féminisme universaliste, c'est,
le combat des Blanches contre les autres, alors oui, non, je suis pas une universaliste, je suis pas une féministe universaliste, ça, c'est évident.
OK. Très bien. Voilà, mais comme ça-
C'est plus clair comme ça ?
Bah oui, mais comme ça, c'est clarifié.
Et en fait, c'est-à-dire que, ce que je, en faisant ça aussi, et je sais que c'est pas simple, mais je suis quelqu'un de compliqué et de plus nuancé qu'on le pense et sans aucune certitude.
Mais c'est-à-dire que je réfute le droit à quiconque de dire à ma place ce que je suis.
Oui, c'est sûr.
Donc si j'ai envie de dire que je suis universaliste, je mets derrière ce que je veux et je serai, et je suis universaliste.
Voilà. Alors, ça n'aide pas dans le débat public parce que effectivement-
Oui, oui.
Voilà. Mais aussi, parce que certains instrumentalisent aussi. Je veux dire, c'est pas comme si, d'ailleurs, ta définition d'universalisme, est-ce qu'elle est la même que celle de Nadia Geerts ?
J'en sais rien, je ne sais pas. Enfin donc, voilà. Donc non, non, moi, enfin voilà, j'ai pas envie qu'on me colle d'étiquette.
Et ce que je remarque, c'est que je suis, mais presque viscéralement, toujours du côté de celui qui est mis à mal.
Ouais.
Voilà, ça, c'est mon...
Ouais, ton credo.
Voilà.
Très bien. Dans ton histoire politique, est-ce que tu as des exemples de situations où tu étais, en tant que femme, désavantagée, opprimée, mise à mal et où ton combat féministe a pu t'aider ?
Alors, sans doute que oui, mais j'ai envie de te répondre de manière très provocatrice en inversant la chose.
Je pense que c'est mon... Je sais pas si c'est mon féminisme, mais c'est le fait d'être femme qui m'a aidée à être là où je suis.
C'est-à-dire, j'ai été présidente d'Écolo parce que c'était la Bérézina.
Ouais.
Je veux dire, si on n'avait pas eu les ré-, enfin, c'est une analyse a posteriori que je fais, hein, parce que je ne me fais pas d'illusion non plus sur moi-même.
Donc, enfin, moi, j'ai jamais cru à l'homme ou à la femme providentielle, pas plus si c'est moi qu'un autre.
Et on le voit d'ailleurs, hein, Sophie Wilmès est devenue, et ça n'enlève rien à ce qu'elle a fait, est devenue première ministre parce qu'il y avait personne qui voulait le faire.
Moi, je suis montée présidente de parti parce qu'aucune autre ne voulait le faire. Enfin, voilà. Et donc de ce point de vue-là, voilà, c'est pour ça que je dis c'est provocateur, hein, tu vois.
Mais, sinon, est-ce que j'ai des exemples ou des anecdotes ? Mais je suis trop forte en gueule, je pense, pour avoir été vraiment confrontée directement.
Donc un jour, quelqu'un m'a dit : « Oui, j'espère que tu te rends bien compte que si tu es là où tu es, c'est parce que je l'ai bien voulu.
» Alors, est-ce qu'il y avait un élément sexiste derrière ?
Et tu t'es laissée faire ou est-ce que tu es trop forte en gueule ?
Non, écoute, parfois, il y a des choses tellement énormes. Enfin, moi, j'ai jamais cru qu'on me dirait que... Enfin, tu vois, j'aurais jamais imaginé que quelqu'un ose dire ça à quiconque.
Enfin, je veux dire, tu vois, moi, une autre. Et donc tu restes un peu soufflé le temps que, voilà. Il y a des choses comme ça.
Et c'est vrai, hein. Pourtant, je suis effectivement forte en gueule, mais dès qu'il s'agit de moi, c'est plus compliqué.
Je suis plus forte dans le combat pour les autres que pour moi-même, à mon avis.
Autre chose à rajouter sur le féminisme ou on passe à autre chose ?
Oui, je voudrais juste dire effectivement qu'on peut pas sombrer de combat. Je veux dire, que ce soit les femmes du nord ou du sud, qu'elles soient laïques, athées, croyantes, enfin tout ce qu'on veut, etc.
Notre premier combat, il est contre un système et contre un modèle, c'est le patriarcat. Le patriarcat, il s'est aussi installé différemment dans différentes régions du pays, etc.
Et donc, on peut être critique. Il y a pas un féminisme, hein. Et ça, il faut qu'on le garde à l'esprit. Donc, on peut être critique, on peut trouver que certains féminismes vont trop loin ou pas assez loin, etc., etc.
Mais ne jamais se tromper qu'on a un ennemi commun et que notre ennemi, c'est pas les autres femmes. C'est d'abord un système dont, alors aussi, les hommes pâtissent, hein, parce que quand un homme...
Je garde le souvenir d'un homme qui subissait des violences intrafamiliales et quand il a voulu aller porter plainte, le policier s'est moqué de lui.
Oui, ou même—
Ça reste une infinie minorité par rapport au chiffre qu'on connaît des femmes. Donc voilà. Mais ça, pour moi, c'est bien la preuve que c'est pas un combat des hommes contre les femmes, c'est un combat d'hommes et de femmes, le cas éch—,
de femmes et d'hommes, le cas échéant, contre un système.
Ouais. Et même pour parler d'un nombre plus important, le fameux mythe de la virginité est aussi une prison pour beaucoup d'hommes.
Complètement.
Le rôle genré, finalement.
Absolument. Moi, j'ai aussi des gens qui me disaient qu'ils n'osent pas, même pas demander leur congé de paternité parce que c'est mal vu.
Mh.
Enfin, voilà. Donc, je veux dire, c'est contre ça qu'on se bat. Et donc les hommes ont intérêt aussi à être à nos côtés contre le patriarcat.
Et c'est pas un combat, moi, je me bats pas contre les hommes. Je me bats contre un système qui fait du mal à tout le monde.
Le congé de paternité qui a donc été introduit par Gilles Vanden Burre, qu'on a reçu dans ce podcast il y a quelques années.
Vanden Burre, oui.
Oui. En parlant d'universalisme, on m'a susurré, on m'a raconté que tu as certaines théories sur les délinquants issus de l'immigration. Pardon ?
J'ai des théories sur tout.
Oui. Sur les délinquants issus de l'immigration qui le feraient par désir d'intégration. Est-ce que tu peux me parler de ça ?
Oui, oui, tout à fait. Donc moi, c'est pour ça, moi, je fais exploser les cadres, hein. D'abord, à mon avis, mais je t'ai dit, hein, j'irai m'allonger un jour quand je serai plus vieille.
Pourquoi quand tu seras plus vieille ? On peut le faire à n'importe quel âge.
Non, j'ai pas... À mon avis, si je le fais maintenant, je me lève plus. Donc je préfère attendre. Non, oui, c'est-à-dire que, voilà, ces analyses clichés, etc.
Donc quand— Bon, j'ai fait une formation initiale comme assistante sociale, etc. Et donc j'ai fait des stages dans des prisons, j'ai donné des cours à des détenus, etc.
Et c'est clair, quand moi, j'entends les politiques qui disent : « Oui, oui, tous ces étrangers en manque d'intégration, regardez, ils sont pleins dans nos prisons ».
C'est pas vrai. Moi, je dis la merde. Je veux dire, ceux qui étaient en prison à l'époque où moi, je donnais des cours, etc.
C'étaient des jeunes qui volaient, qui dealaient, mais pas pour prendre un billet direct à La Mecque, hein. C'était pour acheter la dernière télévision, le truc, le machin, que la société de consommation nous martelait.
Et c'était pour appartenir à cette société de consommation. C'était pas pour s'en éloigner ou renier. Donc pour moi, c'était
non, c'est dans une volonté extrême d'intégrer la société de consommation dans les, et selon les critères et les, oui,
selon les critères qui sont mis en avant et positivés.
C'est ça qui les amenait à dealer, à voler, je sais pas quoi, et pas, ils allaient pas voler pour prendre un vol direct vers La Mecque.
Et c'est là où, alors c'était provocateur et je grossissais le trait, mais c'était pour dire : « Ne nous trompons pas d'analyse ».
Ces jeunes ne sont pas... Et d'ailleurs, pour le même fait, un jeune pas issu de l'immigration, on peut pas dire ça de sa part.
On peut pas dire que c'est un manque d'intégration. À eux, on le dit pas d'ailleurs. Donc y a autre chose que ça.
Et donc il faut— Ce sont pour moi des analyses trop simplistes et trop faciles.
Oui. Et donc, selon cette analyse-là—
Mais bon, j'aime bien la provocation.
Je peux comprendre. Selon cette analyse-là, ces jeunes-là sont davantage incités à rentrer dans cette société de consommation et à s'intégrer dans cette société de consommation, que de s'intégrer—
C'est-à-dire la valorisation de l'individu, et son, sa— la reconnaissance que tu existes—
Oui
...elle passe par la consommation.
Elle passe—
Pour tout le monde. Pour ces jeunes-là comme pour les autres.
Pour ces jeunes-là—
Comme pour les autres
...comme pour les autres, passent davantage par la consommation que par, disons, des règles éthiques, des règles de—
Bah oui, 'fin il suffit d'allumer la télé quoi. Mais bien sûr. Il suffit d'allumer la télé ou de voir les influenceurs—
Je suis très naïf, moi.
Non, pardon, j'ai pas voulu— Non, non, non, non. Mais je veux dire, quand on voit les influenceurs, etc. Y a tous ces influenceurs qui sont à Dubaï et tout, ça, moi, j'hallucine quoi.
Et donc, 'fin, aujourd'hui, on voit bien, 'fin, pour montrer le poids de ces influenceurs qui sont dans l'image et la consommation et d'outrance, etc.
Moi, je pense que dans la stratégie de vaccination auprès de certains publics, c'est via ces influenceurs-là qu'il faut passer.
Tellement ils ont un poids et une—
Mh.
Voilà. Et donc oui, je— Donc, effectivement, de nouveau, je dis ça et je parle pas de tous les jeunes, etc., etc.
Mais c'est pour essayer de nous forcer à aller plus loin que ce qui semble l'évidence.
Et donc quand tu parles de ces jeunes influenceurs par lesquels il faudrait passer—
Oui, ça, je balance ça comme ça—
Oui, oui, c'est ça. Mais non, mais est-ce que ça comprend également des personnalités comme Hanouna, De Wever ou Greta Thunberg, etc. ?
Oui, c'est-à-dire qu'on doit aujourd'hui mettre en place
des dispositifs qui collent à la réalité des jeunes quoi. Je veux dire, les jeunes, ils regardent pas le Code Éco, malgré toute l'amitié et la confiance que j'ai en Alexander et en Franck Vandenbroeck, ils regardent pas le Code Éco.
Et donc s'il y a des messages à faire passer dans cette gestion de crise, etc., il faut aller, il faut se placer là où les jeunes sont.
Et donc, que ce soit Hanouna et— 'fin voilà, ce sont effectivement des influenceuses auprès de certains publics. Et puis y en a d'autres.
Alors c'est vrai qu'on était dans l'urgence, etc. Mais enfin bon, moi, je pense qu'il y a effectivement des espaces qu'on n'imagine pas où les jeunes s'échangent les informations, etc.
Et que c'est sans doute là qu'il faut investir. C'est-à-dire, c'est un peu le sens de mon propos.
Tout simplement. Très bien. On arrive tout doucement au bout des septante minutes. Qu'est-ce qu'on peut te souhaiter en ce qui concerne ta casquette de ministre de l'Environnement, du Climat, du Développement durable et du Green Deal ?
J'aime bien. En ce qui concerne le féminisme et en ce qui concerne la justice sociale.
De ne pas me perdre, de continuer à tracer ma route.
Aussi simple que ça ?
Absolument.
Très bien. Mais merci beaucoup, Zakia Khattabi, pour ces Septante Minutes.
Merci de ton invitation.
Et chers auditeurs, on se retrouve très bientôt pour un nouvel épisode. Au revoir. Et voilà, c'est déjà tout pour ce quarante-cinquième épisode.
Si vous découvrez Septante Minutes Avec aujourd'hui, bah n'hésitez pas à remonter dans le temps. Y a énormément d'épisodes à découvrir.
Il y a deux mois, je vous annonçais tout plein d'invités. Avec la pandémie, j'ai eu énormément d'ambition. Je me suis dit que c'était l'occasion de choper des invités qui sont habituellement inaccessibles, par exemple à l'étranger.
Et ben, ça n'a pas marché comme prévu. Du coup, j'ai lancé plein d'invitations et soit je n'ai pas eu de réponse, soit une réponse positive, mais sans vraiment pouvoir fixer de date.
Il faut dire que les gens sont vraiment très occupés, donc je les comprends. En l'occurrence, dans les mois qui viennent, normalement, je finirai par réussir à booker Jean-Marc Jancovici, qui est ingénieur
et membre du Haut Conseil pour le climat en France, qui défend une position pro-nucléaire et anti-5G.
On devrait aussi avoir Cécile Vessière au sujet du Kremlin en Occident, qui m'a été recommandée par Marie Peltier. Je vais essayer d'avoir Alice Coffin, même si ça n'a vraiment pas l'air facile.
Et sauf imprévu, cet été, il y aura de toute façon un épisode sur la psychanalyse et pourquoi c'est parfaitement monstrueux.
Quoi qu'il en soit, pour ne rien manquer, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast. C'est gratuit et c'est sur toutes vos plateformes de podcast préférées.
N'oubliez pas de suivre l'émission sur les réseaux sociaux et n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer des messages, que ce soit des encouragements, des critiques ou des suggestions d'invités.
Tout ça me fait énormément plaisir. Je vous dis à très bientôt. Prenez soin de vous.